[Applaus]
[Musik]
australien ist eines der reichsten
länder der welt tatsächlich konnte er
sich bis vor kurzem noch rühmen seit
über 30 jahren keine einzige rezession
erlebt zu haben während die restliche
welt von einer finanzkrise in den
nächste wirtschaftskrise kommt aber auf
der anderen seite könnte er mir jetzt
sofort aus dem stegreif ein einziges
australisches unternehmen denn nachricht
aus denkt mal darüber nach besprechen
hier immerhin über das land ist er als
zukunft einfach mal einen blick auf
städte wie in melbourne sydney uns
vorzustellen die die welt im jahr 2050
aussehen könnte egal welches ranking
wird uns anschauen
australien ist immer an der spitze die
australier genießen den zweithöchsten
mindestlohn der welt mit fast 200
us-dollar pro monat sie haben auch eine
der reichsten volkswirtschaften der welt
in der es sehr einfach ist
unternehmerisch tätig zu sein und
gleichzeitig haben sie einen voll
entwickelten sozialstaat um den sich zb
die usa bereiten würde
als die ganze welt unter der finanzkrise
lässt die australische wirtschaft noch
um 2 prozent selbst erst mit der korona
krise kann sich australien rom in einer
viel besseren situation zu sein als
jedes andere land
australien ist einfach ein reiches land
ein sehr reiches aber kommen wir noch
mal auf die frage von vorhin zurück
kennt ihr irgendwelche australische
unternehmen wahrscheinlich nicht viele
ok manche kennen vielleicht die
fluggesellschaft quantas auch die
bekleidungsmarke rückkehr ins
australische und youtuber kennt
vielleicht doch eine andere rockband
mikrofon hersteller das mikrofon lass
dich gerade streitet ist zum beispiel in
jedem fall sprechen wir hier jedoch über
relativ kleine unternehmen von einem
australien stammenden multinationalen
konzernen ist weit und breit nichts zu
sehen australische pendant zu google
oder bmw fehlanzeige
die heutige frage lautet also woher
kommt eigentlich der beeindruckende
reichtum austral jetzt was hat dieser
kontinent zu bieten was verkauft denn
alle welt dass ihr so reich macht heute
lernen wir diese fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar wie man zuerst mit
einem blick zurück in die geschichte
das land der unbegrenzten möglichkeiten
im jahre 1788 war australien so weit
dass die außenwelt betraf nichts weiter
als eine britische strafkolonie das
heißt es war ein ort an dem das
vereinigte königreich seine gefangenen
schickte möglichst ein weg mit ihm
gewinnt
aber moment mal war das wirklich alles
gesinde wohl kaum denn damit das moderne
australien zu einem der reichsten länder
der welt werden konnte war der
geschäftssinn einer reihe von
draufgängern gefragt der erste unserer
protagonisten ist schon mit adem ein
britischer offizier der spanische merino
schafe nach australien trachtet und ein
wohl imperium gründete so begann
australiens erfolgsgeschichte was mit
folgendem satz verewigt wurde
[Musik]
australien ritt auf dem rücken der
schafe zum wohlstand seitdem ist
australien der führende goldproduzent
der welt geblieben und mister bk das
antlitz wurde auf den banknoten wissen
landes wenig
kleist das ist in australien mehr als
genug platz für große schafherden gehabt
aber die geschichte war auch ein großer
verbündeter der australischen wolle
großbritannien und kaufte er während des
zweiten weltkriegs die gesamte
australische produktion auf und während
des koreakriegs schnellste die preise
ist und wollen die höhe weil die
amerikaner wollen für die bekleidung
ihrer truppen benötigten die zeiten
ändern sich und die käufer auch
[Musik]
goldpreis in australien steigt chinas
nachfrage wieder anzieht aber um mal
denn die australier leben nicht nur von
wolle allein in der mitte des letzten
jahrhunderts brach in australien ein
goldrausch aus der ist durchaus mit
denen anderer länder aufnehmen konnte
und seitdem ist australien noch immer
der wichtigste goldproduzent der welt
außerdem wird ist ein rohstoff gold noch
lange nicht auf in der tat hat
australien alles eisen kohle aluminium
kupfer uran und natürlich erdgas und
erdöl glaubt mir es wäre viel einfacher
für mich auf zu zählen über welche
rohstoffe australien nicht im überfluss
verfügt
und wenn du das worauf die tatsache
berücksichtigen dass der
rohstoffhungrige buch kontinent asien
gleich nebenan liegt haben wir das
vollständige bild vor uns wer also
liefert die natürlichen rohstoffe für
alte das wachstum chinas und asiens ganz
genau australien so liebe zuschauer das
war der grund warum australien so reich
ist den angenehm schnell heute nicht
wahr
also vielen dank und bis zum nächsten
mal ihr könnt jetzt abschalten das video
ist zu ende und ich können wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen was ihr seid noch
immer da ach ja wie konnte ich nur so
unterschätzen und glauben dass lara fans
von visual politik wird ihn mir diese
oberflächliche plattitüde
mit dem automatischen wohlstand durch
rohstoffreichtum abkaufen die konnte ich
noch vergessen dass sie als treue
abonnenten unseres bescheidenen kanals
aus all unseren anderen videos gelernt
habt das natürliche ressourcen nicht
viel zu bedeuten haben diese im
gegenteil der in der regel sogar von
einem fluch befallen sind der
sogenannten holländischen krankheit die
fast alle rohstoffreichen länder ins
verderben reißt
denn wenn natürliche ressourcen jedes
land einfach so reich machen würden wäre
argentinien die schweiz und die schweiz
wäre argentinien
okay ich habe ich vergessen dass wir
vorher kaltzustellen bis auf eine
angenehme genuss temperatur herunter
gekühlt ist haben wir noch kurz zeit die
frage wirklich zu beantworten die frage
wie zum teufel ist australien geschafft
hat den fluch der natürlichen ressourcen
der holländischen krankheit zu entkommen
war es dagegen nämlich keinesfalls er
schon ein hochrisiko patient also passt
gut auf denn eigentlich ist das alles
eine sehr lehrreiche und spannende
geschichte
[Musik]
alte reichtümer neue techniken über
natürliche ressourcen zur verfügung ist
nicht immer eine gute nachricht denn
wenn dem so wäre dann wäre ja afrika der
reichste aller kontinente
wenn ein land natürliche ressourcen
entdeckt tritt normalerweise eines von
zwei szenarien ein
das kongo szenario es hat riesiges
vorkommen und es bilden sich guerilla
gruppen die sich gegenseitig umbringen
um diese auszubauen oder wg dass
venezuela szenario
es hat er gefunden baut seine gesamte
wirtschaft auf dessen ausbootung um und
ist dann ruiniert wenn der marktpreis
für den bio saft in den keller geht das
land versinkt in elend aber wir wissen
gar nicht so weit gehen
das phänomen heißt ja holländische
krankheit bei der erdgas buch in den
niederlanden in den sechziger jahren so
einer starken schrumpfung des
industriellen sektors führte in der
erdgasbranche war viel mehr geld zu
verdienen als mit ehrlicher wertarbeit
außerdem entstanden durch den massiven
gasexport außenhandelsüberschüsse die zu
einer starken aufwertung der heimischen
währung und somit zu einer
verschlechterung der internationalen
wettbewerbsfähigkeit führten das alles
waren starke belastungen für den
niederländischen industrie und er sich
das land erst nach vielen jahrzehnten
erholen konnte aber zurück nach
australien
wie gesagt eigentlich auch ein
hochrisiko patient der diese erfahrung
schon beim goldrausch in den 1800 50er
jahren gemacht hatte und auch der
rohstoff buch in den 2000 2010er jahren
hätte zu einem ähnlichen fiasko führen
können doch siehe da australien hatte
aus der geschichte gelernt und wählte
einen anderen weg
[Musik]
die australier haben wir schon immer
über viele natürliche ressourcen verfügt
aber der eigentliche australische
bergbau begann vor 20 jahren zu jener
zeit hatte australien bereits
demokratische transparente und frei
institutionen schließlich hatte das
britische modell kopiert aber warum war
also wichtig dass die so war weil
australien das perfekte testfeld für die
zukunft plant massiven ausbau der
automatisierung in ganz australien
bergbau roboter rio tinto setzt auf
autonomes bohren
mit anderen worten der australische
bergbau sektor hat nichts mit den
klassischen bergmann mit spitzhacke und
schaufel zu tun im gegenteil mit
institutionen die unternehmensgründung
und wettbewerb zulassen und fördern
mussten australische bergbauunternehmen
auf innovation setzen und so ist heute
der bergbau eine der stärksten
technologieorientierten branchen in
australien überhaupt unternehmen wie bp
und rio tinto sind so etwas wie das
apple der natürlichen ressourcen
australien exportiert also nicht nur
seine rohstoffe exportiert auf die ganze
technologie um sie abzubauen und zu
verarbeiten und das erklärt warum so
viele australische unternehmen die
ressourcen anderer länder ausbreiten
den veräußerten ostküste wollte ein
australisches bergbauunternehmen aber
jetzt so war viel vorarbeit nötig
bereits vor mehr als 50 jahren gab der
damalige premierminister harold der welt
ein vorgeschmack darauf wie das land in
zukunft aussehen könnte
dieses unser australien ist ein riesiger
insel kontinents der größtenteils von
menschen britischer oder andere
europäischer abstammung bewohnt wird und
über ein erbe an nationaler freiheit
persönlicher freiheit und institutionen
einer britischen parlamentarischen
demokratie verfügt geografisch gesehen
sind wir jedoch teil asiens und wir sind
uns zunehmend unsere verwicklung in die
angelegenheiten asiens bewusst geworden
und ja die nicht zu asien war
entscheidend für australiens wirtschaft
hat dank der nachfrage chinesischer
stahlwerke wolle als australiens
wichtigstes exportprodukt überholt sowie
die arabischen länder mit dem ölpreis
boom auf gold gestoßen sind hat
australien in den letzten jahrzehnten
vom wirtschaftswachstum asiens
profitiert australien verbraucht kommt
15 prozent seiner eigenen kohleförderung
und diese ist nicht gerade bescheiden
sage und schreibe acht prozent der
weltweit geförderten kohle kommt aus
australien
was das land zum viertgrößten
produzenten nach china indonesien oder
den usa macht beim export hatte sogar
einen marktanteil von 27 prozent ist
also größter kohleexporteur der welt
allein japan und china kaufen mehr als
die hälfte der australischen kohle
exporte aber moment mal kohle klingt
nicht gerade besonders sauber für die
umwelt und dann schauen wir uns doch mal
an wie australiens geschäfte mit
flüssigerdgas die sogenannten energy
läufen wie ihr wisst kann man erdgas aus
zwei akten transportieren pipeline oder
eben als angie das heißt man kühlt das
gas ist es flüssig ist und schiffe es
dann auf energie tanken um die ganze
welt chinas wirtschaftsboom mappus
atomausstieg haben die nachfrage nach
gasen asien explodieren lassen
und wer da zufällig in der nähe um davon
zu profitieren richtig australien mit
seinen gasreserven nicht dass diese
besonders groß wer kommt ein prozent des
welt vorkommt
zwar verfügt zum beispiel über zehnmal
so viel gas wie australien allerdings
man höre und staune ist australien
trotzdem derzeit größte gasexporteur der
welt wie soll das dann gehen nun selbst
diese verhältnismäßig kleine reserven
reichten dafür aus dass sich die
australische gasproduktion den letzten
zehn jahren verdreifacht hat und von
platz 18 der größten gas förderländer
auf platz sieben aufgestiegen ist
australien ist also ein schritt mehr
daran in den erdgas champions league
aufzusteigen dennis verbraucht nur ein
drittel des geförderten gases selbst was
glaubt ihr also was ist mit den anderen
zeiten macht ganz klar verflüssigen und
ganz cool im tann tanker nach asien
schenken
ihr seht also wir haben es mit der
typischen anamnese eines
hochrisikopatienten der holländischen
krankheit zu tun
eine volkswirtschaft die droht extrem
nicht zu werden von rohstoffexporten wie
hoch dieses risiko tatsächlich ist
werdet ihr jedoch erst jetzt zu sehen
bekommen
[Musik]
die holländische krankheit in der regel
ist die entdeckung natürlicher rohstoffe
der ideale nährboden für korrupte
politiker machthaber und diktatoren mit
all den negativen konsequenzen die sowas
eben nach sich zieht in australien hat
man einmal begriffen dass er
rohstoffreichtum auch mit der
ehrlichsten regierung der welt zu
einigen problemen führen kann wenn man
alles was man tun muss um ein vermögen
zu machen und darin besteht eine chance
zu nehmen und zu grabe und glocken in
australien finden wir dabei immer etwas
lukratives dann ist es klar dass es
keinen großen anreiz gibt andere
industrien als den bergbau zu entwickeln
am anfang mag dies noch gar nicht wie
ein problem aussehen aber schon bald
bereitet sich dadurch eine gefährliche
solche in der gesamten wirtschaft aus
die rede ist von der holländischen
krankheit wie erwähnt wurde dieses
phänomen danach benannt was die
niederlande passiert ist als man dort
gasfeld entdeckt und der holländische
krankheit wirklich verstehen will muss
wissen dass ihre gefährlichkeit nicht
nur darin liegt dass sich die ganze
volkswirtschaft das von ihr befallen
landes in eine einseitige abhängigkeit
ergibt ein ebenso gravierend ist ein
anderes foto der teufelskreis des
wechselkursmechanismus was genau ich
damit meine
also schauen sie uns ein beispiel an
denn das muster ist eigentlich immer das
gleiche
plötzlich mit england riesige mengen
einer natürlichen ressourcen
sagen wir es ist australisches eisen und
man hat ebenso viel eisen dass man es
exportiert und ein unternehmen in
anderen ländern verkauft aber natürlich
ihm was das ist die währung des
internationalen handels der us dollar
mit anderen worten australische
bergbauunternehmen verdienen millionen
und abermillionen von usa aber sie
müssen ihre steuern in australien mit
australischen dollar bezahlen was tun
sie also nun sie kaufen die lokale
währung mit anderen worten sie tauschen
ihre us dollar den australischen dollars
und was bedeutet das alles und auf
einmal schießt die nachfrage nach
australischen dollars in die höhe
und was passiert wenn die nachfrage nach
einer währung in die höhe schießt 0 ihr
wert steigt mit anderen worten anstatt
zu werten
für die währung aufgewertet schaut euch
mal folgendes diagramm
jeder grafik sehen könnt hat sich der
wert des australischen dollars und 2000
bis 2011 im verhältnis zum us-dollar
verdoppelt nach 2011 hat sich diese
bewertung eingependelt der kroner
währungskrise ist der aussie dollar
sogar ein wenig gefallen die australier
bekommt also endlich eine gewisse
inflation zu spielen
ja und ich weiß was ihr euch jetzt fragt
seit wann ist es denn etwas schlechtes
wenn die eigene währung nicht abwerten
theoretisch wäre es noch das beste
szenario für ein land eine starke
währung zu haben
auf diese weise hätten die bürgerlichen
unter inflation und könnten langfristige
investitionen planen tätigen mit anderen
worten durch eine so teure währung haben
die australier mehr kaufkraft als die
menschen in fast jedem anderen land ein
australier kann um die welt reisen alles
würde billig erscheinen sie können sich
viele güter und leistungen aus den
ausland leisten also ein amerikaner oder
europäer richtig und ja da habt ihr
natürlich vollkommen recht aber eine
währung zu haben die stellen nicht
aufwertet bringt auch ein paar probleme
mit sich polen pleite australiens
geschichte der autoproduktion geht zu
ende
zuerst schloss ford an toyota
ausschließlich kunden und natürlich sind
ford und toyota us-amerikanische oder
japanische firmen aber holen obwohl es
teil wollen sie das wahr ist die
australische automarkt geschlecht
[Musik]
zumindest war sie das mal die nummer
2020 wurde die produktion für immer
eingestellt welches symbol für die
notlage in welche die australische
fertigungsindustrie geraten ist die
holländische krankheit hat dazu geführt
dass sie auf allen seiten an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit verliert
[Musik]
bezogen und gehältern ist ist eher
schwierig mit ausländischen unternehmen
zu kooperieren und vielleicht werde die
einwände kommen schon mag wenn das
stimmen würde gäbe es in der schweiz ja
keine fertigungsindustrie mehr und dann
ist ja nicht so ja ihr habt recht der
unterschied besteht jedoch darin dass
die schweiz keine bodenschätze hat und
hier kommt die holländische krankheit
ins spiel
kohle machen es nur profitabel industrie
mit sehr hoher wertschöpfung zu schaffen
aber die menschen die diese industrie
schaffen könnten sind zu sehr damit
beschäftigt in der ultra profitablen
welt des bergbaus zu arbeiten in ein
paar jahren hängt die gesamte
volkswirtschaft dann von der ausbeutung
natürlicher ressourcen ab und dann ist
man zu saudi arabien geworden
wo ich eine vorstellung zu geben bei
mehr als der hälfte der australischen
exporte handelt es sich um natürliche
rohstoffe und in der tat gibt es ein
ranking in denen australien mit anderen
weniger vorbildlichen ländern wie
burkina faso und uganda gleichauf liegt
das ranking der wirtschaftlichen
komplexität dieses ranking misst zum
einen den gras der diversifizierung
eines landes und die differenzierung
seiner produkte zb ist japan das
komplexeste land in diesem index warum
weil japan eine menge einzigartige
technologische produkte exportiert ein
so nicht fernseher hat bestimmte
alleinstellungsmerkmale mit denen er
sich von anderen fernsehern
unterscheidet eine tonne reisen ist
jedoch überall gleich und australien
schreitet in diesem ranking eben sehr
schlecht auch haben da aber nicht
beginnt dieses videos behauptet
australien wäre einen anderen weg dann
hätte aus der geschichte gelernt und
wolle es besser machen und jetzt malen
wir den teufel an die wand und droht
damit dass es auf dem weg ist ein neues
venezuela oder saudi arabien zu werden
ganz und gar nicht denn zunächst einmal
verfügt australien über sehr starke
institutionen so dass wenn der bergbau
nicht mehr profitabel ist andere
industrien entstehen können und
tatsächlich ist genau das auch damals in
den niederlanden passiert die
niederlande sind ja das land das der
holländischen krankheit ihren namen gab
allerdings kann niemand sagen dass sie
heute eine wirtschaft haben der ist an
vielfalt mangelt oder dass sie im
niedergang begriffen sind
und jetzt interessiert und sicher was
genau australiens therapie als das gegen
die holländische krankheit ist nun im
gegensatz zu anderen ländern hat
australien politiker die es verstehen
sich auf das kurzfristige zu
konzentrieren und das erklärt kampagnen
wie die folgende
[Musik]
fabriken firmenserver cds mehr über
diese kampagne bei blumenberg eines der
größten medienbereich wird vom
bundesstaat victoria mit seiner
hauptstadt melbourne gefördert generell
bemühen sich die australischen politiker
die wirtschaft zu diversifizieren
sie versuchen ausländische investitionen
anzuziehen um eine innovative sektoren
zu entwickeln die regierung von victoria
animiert hightech firmen dazu in ihrem
stark zu investieren
die ergebnisse einer solchen kampagne
werden dass auf mittlere sicht zu
erkennen sein und können noch nicht
bewertet werden was wir aber wissen ist
dass eine reihe von jungen australischen
unternehmen bereits begonnen hat die
rede ist von plattform für freiberufler
wie freelancer oder martina designs sind
unternehmen die autobahn oder innovative
software kann und was denkt ihr werden
diese bemühungen zur überwindung der
politischen krankheit ausreichend glaubt
ihr dass australien der ideale ort für
die gründung eines neuen innovativen
unternehmens sein könnte würdet ihr nach
australien gehen um dort ein start-up zu
gründen wie immer sind wir auf eure
kommentare schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat sagt
musste kein leid geteilt es mit freunden
und vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren mach's gut und bist du
[Musik]